Oh Khloe Kardashian seems to be soaking  up every second with her daughter true  but she's not staying quiet about the  haters who mom shame her what is wrong  with people  after four-month-old true received this  baby bentley as a gift from Kimora Lee  Simmons one Instagram user accused Chloe  of quote embedding materialism in truths  brain with the toy car the new mom  didn't let that comment slide and clap  back at the internet troll writing she's  a baby who received a beautiful sweet  gift and I was so excited to put her in  it and take a picture  adding I'm enjoying every single moment  I can with my sweet angel baby true  [Music]  [Applause]